it's great to be joined today once again
by economist richard wolf who is
professor emeritus of economics at my
alma mater the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst currently a
visiting professor at the new school
university in new york city so professor
what we've been starting to dig in to
Donald Trump's hundred day plan and
really specifically looking at the
pieces of that plan that relate to the
economy and sort of comparing and
contrasting whether those policies if
made effective would make America great
again as the phrase goes particularly
for the middle class which is a group
that Donald Trump really tried to appeal
to so there's a number of areas we could
look at on this his claims about
withdrawing from NAFTA and starting
trade wars tax policy we've already seen
that his tax cuts are not going to be
nearly as big as he initially said and
actually the lowest tax bracket is going
to go from ten to twelve percent
whatever angle you think is the most
relevant and analysis for the middle
class I'm glad to start there well let
me give you what may not be the welcome
news it is that an honest appraisal of
what has gone on so far is such a bundle
of contradictions that I would be beware
of anyone who claims to say it will
unbalance the positive or negative for
this group or that group contradictions
are so enormous that even if you read
closely some of the pieces that are
headlined as though they know which way
it's going when you read down into the
body of the article if it's a decent
reporter or commentator they will say
but you know it could be and then they
basically tell you it could be the
opposite of what the first part of the
article assertive and I think that's a
flaw in the reporter I think that's
because mr. Trump either doesn't know
how to formulate a governmental program
or doesn't want to reveal what it is
he's in fact going to do or doesn't much
care one of those because
it doesn't really compute let me give
you some examples yeah he names a fellow
from the South priced to be his health
secretary a man who's committed
apparently above all else in life to
undo the Affordable Care Act often known
as Obamacare and when he summarizes what
he's going to do he's going to quote
unquote let the market decide in other
words not to cover people as a right as
a feature of citizenship in the United
States the way most other industrial
countries do but rather to let supply
and demand and profit-making companies
produce whatever outcome they tend to
produce it's the market idea which has
usually been a venir for self-serving of
the business community anyway but here
the remarkable thing is the same day
that he announces mr. prices selection
he also announces with great excitement
that he and vice president-elect pence
are heading off to Indiana having
muscled he claims the carrier
corporation into not making the market
dictated decision of moving about a
thousand jobs to Mexico because what the
market dictates to that company is
precisely what mr. Trump is there to
prevent happening well on the one hand
we're gonna let the market decide on the
other hand we're not officially but
let's pause there for a second cuz this
gets into something that's so
interesting it and yes you know we're
gonna get deep delve really deeply into
the entire carrier thing uh tomorrow so
I'm seeing in the proposals a sort of
unusual mix of carrot and stick policies
so a carrot policy would be for example
reducing the corporate tax rate and
taxes on the rich to try to sort of lure
them with the carrot as the phrase might
be uh to make investments in new
businesses or the it's basically
supplies
I trickle-down economics and at the same
time you have stick ideas that this idea
that Trump floated which I guess now
he's going to back off of of a very
harsh penalty for companies that move
jobs out of the u.s. to other countries
is this relatively unusual this
combination of carrot and stick policies
to be floated or is there something
interesting to explore there that maybe
isn't often looked at well again it's
possible that mr. Trump and his advisors
really are prepared to muscle and
threaten our companies that do not make
market based decisions of the sort they
think will make them look good
politically it's possible it has not
been the behavior of most governments in
the United States over the last
half-century neither Republican nor
democrat uh they sometimes talk a little
bit about doing all of these things but
the reality time and again has been to
basically not offend corporate America
for fear of the political consequences
of doing it there is a toleration among
the corporations for the language they
know that campaigns have rhetoric that
goes over the top they expect it they're
not badly thrown by it they assume it's
mostly a froth that will subside once
the election is over and i think mr.
Trump having narrowly to say the least
won this race would not be in a strong
position to do something that might
really unite corporate America against
what he is and what he represents would
be a strange thing for a man in his
position to do given our history and
given his vulnerability let's talk a
little bit about trade deals many times
trade deals are not really trade deals
they're multinational corporate power
and ability to skirt national law
deals but to the extent that trade deals
are trade deals we are now starting to
see more and more pieces be published by
economists and journalists and
commentators saying you know up the
actual trade deals that are currently in
place do keep down the costs of many
products for Americans and what Donald
Trump is sort of ignoring is that
although he might uh make himself feel
good for keeping a campaign promise he
may or may not have understood when he
made it by starting to get out of trade
deals he sees as unfavorable for
Americans this is going to have there's
another side of the coin to these trade
deals isn't there so can you talk a
little bit about that I mean are there
if there is a trade war first of all
does anybody win and number two are
there ways in which these trade deals
are good for Americans that is not
really being discussed absolutely the
answer to both of them is that there are
trade deals and then again there are
trade deals nothing is easier than to
look at a deal that often takes fifty
hundred two hundred pages to lay out the
specifics of and find something you
don't like you think we could have done
better you will do better this is
theater this is not serious work a trade
deal usually involves many partners and
even if it's only two partners bilateral
trade deals it's a matter of give and
take like most deals you get this
advantage but you give up that advantage
otherwise the partner doesn't make the
deal with you and and that's the normal
situation has the United States
benefited from trade deals the answer is
yes and no some industries have done
real well others haven't the industries
that suffer when we open our borders the
production abroad have disappeared in
the United States we have a much much
smaller automobile industry in America
than we used to because we import cars
or we let foreign companies set up
inside the United States the same is
true with computers the same is true
with cameras and a whole host of other
products those industries have either
disappeared in the United States or in
order to survive they moved production
abroad which is indeed what the carrier
corporation is facing as its problems it
can't compete unless it has lower wages
than it pays in the United States
confronting the United States with a
conundrum if you want to keep the
products cheap you have to lose the job
if you keep the jobs you have to be
prepared to pay very high prices and
basically all the wheeling and dealing
is about that struggle in terms of which
side will prevail because it has more
power one thing to add if mr. Trump had
the slightest intention to rhina go we
negotiate trade deals in such a way that
the American middle class is the
beneficiary then he would have to make
use of the apparatus of the trade union
movement in this country of academics in
this country who have been working and
advocating for such a solution for 50
years he never speaks to them he never
invites them he does not include them in
any of the negotiations or plans never
has makes no statement that he ever will
which means that to imagine that when
all the dust clears a billionaire
president weeb ago she ain't trade deals
will make sure because he wants us to
trust him that he will take care of
everybody without including any of the
putative beneficiaries in the process
last thing i want to touch on in the
limited time we have the one of these
hundred day plan items is to label china
a currency manipulator aside from
whether that's an accurate allegation
does that labeling actually have any
real-world impact in and of itself it
could because it could be the prelude to
being tariffs upon them something else
that mr. Trump said during the campaign
variously thirty five percent or forty
five percent to do any of this is to
declare economic warfare on the People's
Republic of China and to do that is to
take a very large step that in history
has often ended up in a transition from
economic warfare to the military kind
let's remind ourselves quickly half of
the goods that come into the United
States from China are produced by
subsidiaries of American corporations
that have set up shop there to cut them
out of the American market with a tariff
is a direct assault by Trump on the
biggest multinational corporations in
the United States who've invested at
least three hundred billion dollars to
produce in China for export to the
United States it's not really going to
happen do you think that's likely second
example the Chinese are the major
creditor of the United States they own
the People's Republic of China more US
Treasury bills obligations of the United
States than any other country on earth
the chaos that would erupt if they
stopped buying in effect lending to the
United States government is hard to
imagine but the power of it is
unmistakable do you really want to
provoke that kind of confrontation and
thirdly China is the second most
important economy in the world they
build up their industries over last 30
years by export you close the world's
largest export market to China you are
plunging that country into extreme
measures and they are a very powerful
nuclear armed society one really has to
scratch one's head and wonder whether
mr. Trump is just spinning his wheels or
whether he's crazy if he's actually
going to move in that kind of direction
well we may find out sooner than later
we've been speaking with economist
richard wolf always great having you on
thank you David look forward to
next time